the dating advice for gurus online seems
to boil down to just be successful bro
given that women rate 80% of men as
physically unattractive and 50% of men
are below average intelligence what's
the advice for those 40% of men the bar
is set unbelievably low like the average
American man is obese Divorced with less
than 1K in the bank I think that the
internet over indexes on objective
metrics of success and doesn't account
for what happens in person you will see
regularly people and guys that are
charismatic funny sexy in person batting
way outside of their league if you were
to just look at them from an online
perspective basically I would say don't
overthink what the internet says dude if
you go to the gym three times a week for
a year you're probably in the top
percentile of all Fitness people on the
planet if you spend 300 bucks on a
relatively okay wardrobe you're probably
better dressed than most of the guys
that you're going to walk past just try
a bit and you will already be probably a
six or seven out of 10